Mallorca für die einen ein Geschenk von
Mutter Natur für die anderen eine Woche
im Jahr absolute Ekstase ca zweieinhalb
Stunden Flugzeit von Deutschland
entfernt liegt die Insel auf der in
Hochzeiten stündlich über 12.000
touristenlampen ich will wissen wie lebt
es sich auf der Insel fernab von
bierhelm MegaPark und Bettenburg was
macht es so attraktiv hier zu Boden und
viel wichtiger wie lebt man günstig was
ist teuer auf Mallorca Spanien
hallo da seid Ihr herzlich willkommen in
Wohnung Nummer 1 Palma de Mallorca
falsch Palma de Mallorca ist die Stadt
ne auf Mallorca
30 Quadratmeter voll eingerichtet
absolutes Prachtexemplar 150 Meter vom
Strand entfernt im Prinzip genau das was
der absolute Traum für eine
Einzimmerwohnung auf Mallorca wäre
direkt links neben dem Eingang finden
wir eine kleine Küche komplett voll
ausgestattet mit Backofen zwei Feld
großes Kochfeld Dunstabzugshaube großer
Kühlschrank und so weiter und jetzt
fragt ihr euch mit Sicherheit schon
warum bin ich alleine da und nicht mit
Makler alle Makler die wir angefragt
haben haben entweder keine so kleinen
Wohnungen in der Vermietung gehabt weil
wir probiert haben deutschsprachige
Makler zu finden oder mieten und kaufen
deutlich deutlich größer also im Sinne
einer Finca einer Villa wozu wer später
im Video kommt so eine kleine Wohnung
kommt und kein Deutscher Makler dem er
angefragt haben organisieren und
deswegen mussten wir auf den Airbnb
ausweichen haben aber trotzdem alle
wichtigen Daten und Fakten mit dabei die
Wohnung könnte de facto nicht weiter von
der Schinkenstraße und schlagerpartys
entfernt sein im Norden der Insel dreht
sich in der ältesten Stadt Mallorcas
Alcudia alles eher um naturkultur und
alles wird etwas entspannter angegangen
und das spiegelt sich auch in der
Wohnung wieder an der Küche vorbei geht
es raus auf unseren tatsächlich ziemlich
großen Balkon also wir haben eine Menge
Platz so viel Platz deswegen eigentlich
gar nicht so richtig brauchen aber eine
Sitzmöglichkeit für zwei Personen um
Wein zu trinken oder essen was man sich
im Takeo geholt hat von einem Gewächs äh
gewächsanbau das nicht gebaut ist weil
sich die airbt die Leute natürlich nicht
darum kümmern würden keine Aussicht aufs
Meer und direkt hinter der Kamera ein
bisschen Wassersport Kram den man sich
kostenlos mitnehmen kann zu mehr und
nicht besonders hübsch aber sehr
funktional unsere Klimaanlage drin geht
weiter mit ordentlich Platz also wir
haben wirklich genug Platz um uns frei
zu bewegen einen Sessel der etwas random
steht und einem zweiten wechselte auch
etwas random steht einen kleinen
Essbereich für zwei Personen das reicht
allemal insgesamt finde ich ist es
tatsächlich ganz schick ausgestattet und
bevor ich euch das Badezimmer den
Schlafbereich und den Schrank zeige hat
uns der Vermieter gesagt dass er glaubt
dass diese Wohnung ungefähr so
eingerichtet wie sie ist in der
Langzeitmiete bei
1100 € liegen würde was komplett
geisteskrank ist es hängt natürlich aber
auch immer von der Saison ab in der
Sommerzeit ist so eine Wohnung und ich
übertreibe nicht wahrscheinlich in
dieser Lage im Norden nicht mal ganz
unten wo ihr mit euren Fußballverein in
den meisten Fällen Hinfahrt macht diese
Wohnung im Monat wahrscheinlich sowas
wie drei dreieinhalb tausend Euro Umsatz
über Alien wie über booking über
irgendwelche vermietungsplattform was
völlig geisteskrank ist aber so ist es
nun mal im letzten Jahr alleine sind die
Mieten auf dem Balearen im Durchschnitt
14,5% gestiegen und das muss man sich
mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen denn
das ist nur der Durchschnitt am
krassesten getroffen hat es dann Tanja
und an aber auch Alcudia ist mit 28%
mieteinstieg im letzten Jahr wirklich
krass dabei nur mal so zum Vergleich in
Deutschland ist der durchschnittliche
Mietpreis pro Quadratmeter bei 8,90 €
will man aber in Alcudia eine Wohnung
mieten bezahlt man durchschnittlich
13,20 € und den anderen sogar 16 € 50
also Alcudia ähnlich teuer wie Köln und
anderer hat fast so teuer wie München
das alles natürlich aus dem Grund des
gerade im Sommer super viele Touristen
kommen und genau solche Wohnung wie wir
jetzt auch gerne in Strand Nähe mieten
wollen der Durchschnitt der etwas mehr
als 900.000 Einwohner von Mallorca
verdient etwa 22.000 € brutto im Jahr
und denkt man dabei an die ein
drittelsregel also das Verhältnis von
Gehalt zu dem was man anmiete zahlt gibt
es hier ein krasses Missverständnis und
euch erklären warum das so ist muss ich
glaube nicht Einbauschrank wie man es
eigentlich mittlerweile muss ich sagen
weil ich ja schon einige Videos dazu
gedreht habe aus jedem Land gewohnt ist
außer aus Deutschland Holz bester Stein
weißer Boden weiße Küche Einrichtung
gefällt mir ziemlich gut und man merkt
dass es gerade frisch gemacht wurde ein
Doppelbett ja es ist ein Doppelbett
bequem ist es nicht unbedingt das
Steinhart es ist steinhart aber es ist
ein Bett wäre im Zweifelsfall dann eben
das womit man in der eingerichteten
Wohnung in der Langzeitmiete leben
müsste gut wäre das für den Preis
allerdings nicht und daran vorbei geht
es ins Badezimmer mit Waschmaschine mit
nahezu bodentiefer Dusche also
eigentlich nicht wir haben so 10 cm
Absatz aber wenn das hier schon so
schick und sauber und toll und
begeistert ist wie sieht es dann wohl in
der großen Immobilie aus für die wir aus
dem Norden komplett in den Süden fahren
müssen Malle ist tatsächlich gar nicht
so klein wie man das vielleicht denken
würde ungefähr viermal so groß wie
Madeira es gibt überall Autobahnen und
so weiter und das Wetter endlich mal
alle typisch wieder perfekt wenn über 30
Grad ist natürlich umso wichtiger egal
ob in mal oder in Deutschland genug zu
trinken und halt Rate zu bleiben und er
ab ist dafür die perfekte Begleitung
wenn er Großteil von euch wird er hat ja
schon längst kennen ist jetzt die
stilbeutel gibt es verschiedene Flaschen
hier natürlich auch verschiedene Duft
Richtung denn das Konzept ist so einfach
wie genial ihr Tricks durch diese Duft
indem sie hochzieht
[Musik]
trinkt und dadurch Luft durch ein
kleines Loch hier mit in eure Nase zieht
während des Trinkens Tricks die Augen
Kopf da rein irgendwas zu trinken mit
Geschmack obwohl es eigentlich nur
Wasser mit einer Duftnote ist also ein
unheimlich gutes Konzept und das ist
richtig geil für jeden der wie ich
Probleme damit hat immer genug Wasser zu
trinken und dank der super großen
Vielfalt der Pots wird es niemals
langweilig zu trinken bei den über 30
verschiedenen Sorten weiß man gar nicht
so richtig wo man anfangen soll mit den
absoluten classic Geschmäckern wie
Pfirsich oder Limette macht man auf
jeden Fall nichts falsch und für die die
ist etwas außergewöhnlicher mögen gibt
es dann dürfte die Kokosnuss oder
Eiskaffee mein absoluter Favorit ist
Cherry aber probiert doch einfach selber
mal aus über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung könnt ihr auch
Auschecken vielen Dank an er für die
Unterstützung euch viel Spaß weiter der
zweiten teuren Immobilien Immobilien
zwei das absolute Highlight dieses
Videos ich habe Monja von Tanz und Krone
Immobilien hier aus Mallorca ist richtig
von Mallorca
nehmen genau von Mallorca dabei und wir
schauen uns jetzt ein absolutes
Prachtexemplar an super
[Musik]
auf der anderen Seite der Insel ein
Katzensprung von der Hauptstadt Palma
entfernt liegt diese Villa in der Region
calablaba und obwohl wir augenscheinlich
in direkter Schlagdistanz zum Ballermann
sind so dass man meinen könnte direkt
auf der Performance von knossi und Marc
Eggers im MegaPark zu sein wurden wir
krass überrascht also wir haben hier ein
freistehendes Haus mit 400 Quadratmetern
Wohnfläche aber eine Besonderheit wir
haben das ganze aufgeteilt auf zwei
Etagen und neben dem Eingang hier zu Fuß
gibt es natürlich einen großen Einfahrt
für Autos zwei Autos haben in der Garage
auch noch Platz da kommen wir gleich
auch noch zu genau die Kamera von innen
auch betreten wenn man ankommt wenn man
Lebensmittel oder so hat dass man direkt
durchgehen kann also ans Haus
angeschlossen
hier befinden wir uns im ersten
Wohnbereich mit einer kleinen
eingebauten Küche es ist groß das ist
toll angelegt also alles was man braucht
wie viel Schlafzimmer wie viel
Badezimmer haben wir in diesem Haus wir
haben hier vier Schlafzimmer vier Bilder
zwei Wohnbereiche eigentlich auch zwei
Küchen und das können wir uns auch
gleich anschauen wir haben meistens
sieht dass jedes Schlafzimmer auf sein
eigenes Badezimmer hat teilweise noch
mit Ankleidezimmer also eine schöne
Privatsphäre für jeden das hier ist der
besagte Eingang aus der Garage direkt
ins Haus von dem gesprochen
wenn man was zu tragen hat Lebensmittel
etc ja eine Garage ne aber eine gut
ausgestattete Garage mit einer Menge
Einbau Schränken
hier haben wir ein Schlafzimmer mit Bart
und Suite alles dabei Einbauschränke
haben wir hier ja meistens ist das ja in
Spanien so dass man diese
Kleiderschränke tatsächlich als
Einbauschränke hat man braucht nicht
separat noch irgendwas zu stellen das
macht natürlich schon einiges her wenn
einfach nicht viel extra Zeug im Raum
rumsteht dann kommt man rein es ist ein
Raum und kann sich den so gestalten wie
man möchte vom Essbereich riesen
Schiebetüren allgemein unheimlich viel
Glas ne und das hat auch seinen Grund
300 Sonnentage im Jahr können ein guter
Grund sein hier auf die Insel zu kommen
sind aber eben auch ziemlich heiß es
gibt natürlich mehrere Aufgänge vor dem
Haus hinter dem Haus überall das ist
jetzt der Eingang von Straßenseite und
jetzt schaut euch das an
ist ja eigentlich im Grunde sage ich mal
so ein bisschen wie unten ich habe
dieses offene Wohnkonzept habe hier
natürlich meine ja mega-küche wo einem
einfach immer das Herz ein bisschen
höher schlägt wenn ich nämlich hier
koche
also Kochen mit Meerblick ist doch
irgendwie richtig richtig cool ne und
neben der Küche haben wir einen großen
Essbereich der Platz für acht Personen
wenn man sich ein bisschen eng
zusammensetzt vermutlich auch noch ein
paar mehr im Wohnbereich und hier links
geht es vermutlich in die Schlafzimmer
genau genau
okay so dann sind wir hier einmal links
im ersten Schlafzimmer mit Wartung Suite
ja schickes kleines Zimmer vermutlich
wäre das ein Kinderzimmer genau genau
richtig richtig schick so dann haben wir
hier noch ein anderes wunderbares
Schlafzimmer nicht morgens aufwache kann
ich auch direkt wieder den schönen
Meerblick genießen und das ist master
bedroom
bedroom sieht man ja schon hier habe ich
eine schöne
einbaugeschichte noch für die für die
Garderobe obwohl ich in dem anderen
Schlafzimmer auch noch was habe ein
wahnsinns Badezimmer schön groß schön
geräumig und Badewanne mit kann ich auch
noch genau in der Badewanne sitzen und
kann auch noch aus mir gucken genau hier
haben wir dann Schlafzimmer Nummer vier
auch mit einem Ankleidebereich richtig
richtig gut eine Menge Platz für Gäste
Kinder Schwiegereltern wäre auch immer
zu Besuch kommt und das ist der was ich
am Anfang sagte das ist ja verschiedene
Möglichkeiten gibt du bist in einem Haus
aber du hast ja tatsächlich wie zwei
separate Wohnbereich e so und wenn jetzt
auch wie die Eigentümer sag mal wenn ich
schon größere Kinder habe ältere Kinder
hat dann die möchten ja vielleicht auch
ihren Partner machen und dann finde ich
es perfekt der zweite Terrasse mit
zweiter Lounge und das Highlight
es ist wirklich geschmackvoll
zusammengestellt also von den
Materialien das haben wir jetzt schon
mehrfach gesagt Holz Weißglas graue
Fliesen heller Pool Fußballplatz diese
Schattierung gefällt mir unheimlich gut
und jetzt aber zu alles entscheidenden
Frage ich habe mein Lebensmittelpunkt in
Köln ich arbeite von dort und denke mir
ach ich nehme vielleicht alle Jungs die
mit mir arbeiten einfach mit ich komme
mir vorstellen dass zu mieten wo landen
wir bei dieser Immobilie jetzt konkret
oder kannst du uns eine Preisrange gehen
ich würde sagen dass du wenn du sowas
mietest irgendwo zwischen 11 12 13
14.000 € im Monat bist vermutlich mit
Recht aber etwas zu hoch für mich
momentan das Ding ist man zahlt in
calablawa die direkte Nähe zum Flughafen
zu Palma und die Sicht auf die Player
was ziemlich geil ist keine Frage aber
mir wäre es das Geld nicht wert ich
glaube ich würde die halbe Stunde extra
Fahrt vom Flughafen in den Norden auf
mich nehmen um deutlich günstiger und
deutlich ruhiger zu leben keine Frage es
gibt bestimmt Leuten denen das
unheimlich viel wert ist also
offensichtlich weil genau diese
Bauplätze unheimlich viel Geld kosten
und die Häuser und Wohnungen eben auch
aber ich würde mich im Norden glaube ich
etwas wohler fühlen das Haus an sich
finde ich aber unglaublich nice so viel
Platz zu haben einen eigenen Garten
einen eigenen Pool und ein Fußballplatz
ist schon was ganz besonderes und
natürlich nichts vergessen auch 400
Quadratmeter Wohnfläche es bleibt ein
schöner Traum und hoffentlich gutes
Entertainment für euch wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasst mir gerne ein Like da
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
dann sehen wir uns nächste Woche zum
Porsche Trader wieder macht's gut ciao
[Musik]